I bought a where it's twenty. Florist. Visioning. Is going to stop us.
I came up to name that and decide on such and you know. All right. All right. I'm florist a vision.
When i lived in sydney. I was francesca. But since moving up here. I've decided that i like my name.
To come back to me as a mantra. And soft call myself. Burgeon forest where i came to nimbin. India early eighties.
For a three week holiday. And found myself having my first. Environmental arrest.
And the amount of protecting the forest. Environment became an issue. From that point on it was a night.
I didn't stay i actually had a very close connection with king's cross for ten years.
And i was very fond of king's cross. So i had a double pole.
In you came up here when he was five and fell in love with the place. So he kept pulling back.
And so i kept a very close connection with people from the time when there were environmental. Activated. With me.
And so over the years so close. Kept very close friendships and. It was no moon. Feeling to come and live up here.
To run. When you got here a few years back. To help run the rainforest information center in liz mill.
And i was there for about a year and a bit. And then i moved to living in teepees.
I've decided that i had to get closer to the ground. Closer to where. Mother nature was suffering.
And feeling what it is that we need to do. Really you know. We just asked directly.
You environment what needs to be done and becomes really really very clear that certain things need to be done
and you do them. You know what. I love for freedom. Is my motivating force. And i like to live in an environment where.
I'm not closed in my best. Expression for the head is maybe the aboriginal way. The gun yeah.
I had a gun you know which had no separation between inside and outside and. That is how i feel best.
That's how i feel. I am living. To my utmost. I have rather than hiding away. You know. In a box. You know.
In the house and. It feels like to pick a perfect thing for me to be doing. You know my body loves dancing.
I can get into singing.
I can do things that come much more spontaneously if you living in close connection with nature. What was.
Knowing that the rain forest. Yes. I know that the rain forest. Is the womb of life and.
There's only a few remnants left on the planet. In relation to what it was not so very long ago.
So it is of the utmost importance that we protect these remnants and.
Live when we live in close proximity with these remnants living totoo understanding of our environment.
And the total connection with it. That is my inspiration is radio.
So he actually had to straddle both worlds i lived in kings cross. For a lot of that time he's only been here.
Proximity the same time as me. For most. K. Ok. Sorry about that but experience of it is all right. My son. Emu.
Lived in kings cross for the first twelve years of his life and. He only had certain times away from case cross.
Appear. But that was enough for him to become an environmentalist. And he has gone to america on his own twice.
To sing from coast to coast. Environmental songs. And so. He keeps coming back to this place. This place. He lives. So.
Yes education. He went to preschool. The brush cut his buy a ride on the water's edge.
Because that was the healthiest place for him to be. He's living in kings cross. And he loved it.
And he stay they want to extreme here. So that. He started school. One year late.
And then he went to a lera demonstration school which was a school in the richmond suburbs a gang and.
It had a good effect on amy or in go ahead. Three mile teaches through his primary school. And he was able to relate.
For many hours a day with a mild which was great because he was being brought up by me and.
When he left when he left sydney. At the age of twelve. In your time and schooling. He'd made it to go clews boys high.
But we just went. Submerged and. He didn't emerge again. Tried one term at high school when he was fifteen.
And he didn't find it very inspiring. So he went on the hill and kohli caught. Bandwagon he used to sing.
When she spoke in her election campaign and. That's what he's chosen to do. He's just a musician.
Expressing what's happening around his sets. He's just because he's rich.
His education is so far ahead of anything that. The education system can possibly provide that. It just.
It just defies all curricula.
So it shows you know that there isn't a name than you find when you dance with the name been people.
And don't exchange. Any words. You feel such high regard for them. You feel such a powerful. Bonding.
And then when you actually do exchange words. Then mostly good words.
And people have feeling for one another they recognize each other's right to exist.
And credibly even tolerant and have a trifle less fear than most people out there like that so i'm not he was my first.
Connection. And now tonight is just so beautiful. The forest in there is just so magnificent.
And my first connection to this place was that i stayed in a wooden dome. It was like a small cathedral.
It was just so beautiful so well placed and build with love and feeling. It's a great place. This.
Couldn't help but live. As an icon in my in my living in sydney. I could always look back to this and say well.
This exists. The ones that see the forest. Is for me letting go. Thinking of myself as the center of the universe and.
Just becoming pattern. And amazing array. Creatures. Smell just. The song. Lizards. Snakes.
I just love being spiritual. Yes. Sometimes i will kilometers. Through the night with no moon and.
I just rolled through this truly magical place has lost its just a kind of.
I think the religious was call it a calling. For me.
It's just down the way he's going down to the world a whole lot say. Oh yes that's good.
It's a taking responsibility and enjoying your life. Enjoying your life.
Doing things that you know you should be doing. And getting a lot of joy in creating out of the creativity.
I'm doing a little poem a culture hillside with bush has made. And love you close down at the bottom with frog song.
Every night. By an empty theater. With frogs. About tens of righties. Just to sing the song. Night for.
It's the kind of thing that he could only have a few little love. And you're prepared to protect my secret.
So that's the attitude i have is that. I'm still in the dog and. I give massage twice a week.
Mondays and fridays union. I do something from. Esoteric knowledge of osteopathy. And she asked sue.
And i use my entire body for delivery. My feet. My smile bows and.
I bring a lot of structural change in people's bodies. And i really enjoy doing that.
I'm more concerned with moving away from the attitude of money being really important. I am more concerned.
And with people actually prove. Starting to produce food and produce their own food. That i think is most central.
To focus upon. You know food production. Able to sustain itself. So it's been a rural subsidy. Most said yes.
Can you can i stay here. Yeah. The goal is to create a rule subsidy and.
Give people an opportunity to branch out and start something totally fresh and new.
And that's the promise of aquarius aquarius is the promise of. Fresh approach to same and.
That's what the fist book is going to be showing. It has to show that. Otherwise there's absolutely no hope.
It has to be a new way of doing things.
We've had so many wars in close connection with one another we haven't had a new listing period between generations in
peace. So our brains are a bit scrambled. If you go to the age and you need to kill.
You need at least four generations. To recover. Priest psyche to recover.
So if we can find a health and well being in the rainforest. Not going to find it anyway. You know it's best. So yeah.
We have. At the drop of a hat we celebrate. Celebrate. Anything and everything and.
We have minister for cultural affairs and. He ensures a healthy. Number of dances and get togethers and.
Places for displaying. Just what. Yes yes yes yes yes we kind of here together. And we want to have a good time yet.
This is such a beautiful planet. It's such a mistake to have anything else other than a very good time for.